so are you retired or retired yeah I
think that's the biggest question all of
your fans have yeah are they actually
retired I've said it years ago because I
I think I had done it 10 years at the
time yeah and I was just thinking like
I don't know if it's like a middle-aged
crisis or something or maybe just
mid-life yeah like you're 30. I've done
this 10 years and I'm just like do I
want to keep doing it at this pace for
like another 10 years and I was like
[ __ ] no so yeah I just made a conscious
choice to just like
focus more on what so you're like
retired yeah I mean I guess I had the
choice of like oh do I want to quit or
do you want to if you didn't enjoy
making videos yeah I presume you would
stop exactly and I still enjoy it but I
don't like the pressure that you kind of
put onto yourself and I am
always chasing the algorithm and doing
whatever like people want so yeah just
doing what I like and focusing on that I
feel like why not well like why make it
and I feel like you're past like 10
years as well like it's been just an
absolutely [ __ ] insane it's been a
[ __ ] ride yeah yeah like you've done
so many you've done so much [ __ ] in such
a short span of time where it's just
like I'm good now yeah yeah I don't
blame you man you guys are like in the
midst of it it seems like nothing so
busy I think so appreciate advice do you
have then from uh have former person all
right okay enjoy it well you can [ __ ] it
I want to have my dream hack uh moment
where
I go on stage and sing why have you seen
that I love that I love that clip
no I haven't seen this I'm so sorry
okay
[Applause]
this is like early early YouTube
this is like my favorite clip I'm glad
you enjoyed it it's so good I don't know
why like maybe you guys can relate to
like just thinking yeah yeah that's fine
I can do that because they like they I
feel like sometimes they put your idea
or there's an idea gets said you're like
yeah sure and then you don't actually
think about it and then it happens and
you're like this was a horrible idea I
didn't even think it was a horrible idea
like yeah okay so uh I had done YouTube
for like a year it doesn't matter but
there's a convention like a land big
land party a dream called dream hack
right yeah I guess it's pretty famous
now yeah
um and they have a stage and they were
like do you want to come to dream hack
and like play games on stage and I was
like yeah sure all right absolutely like
oh recognition by someone that's awesome
yeah yeah and I had nothing planned and
at the time I uh played like Happy
Wheels and I sang karaoke and I thought
that was like the funniest [ __ ] ever I
mean it was pretty funny
yeah and then I was like [ __ ] what do I
do on stage I have no nothing prepared
like I just had my laptop they're like
all right cool you've already left up go
on stage here you go entertain these
people and I was just like all right I
guess we play some happy wheels that was
fine and then if for some reason I
thought like playing karaoke was gonna
be a good idea so I sang on stage what
did you see uh take on me oh my God
and it's just a clip of uh it's a nice
clip of me it's good it's just funny
because I'm like singing and I'm into
like two can't be it's just terrible you
cut to the audience and they're just
like
I think I think every single YouTuber
needs a moment like that it's like you
just you just I don't know why like I
encourage it's so much [ __ ] I do but for
some reason that to me is just funny
like that it's funny it's great how long
ago was this uh it must have been 10
years ago yeah I mean like it's stuff
like that is where you look back on you
like that was the funniest [ __ ] yeah
that happened I think it's like I had a
great time doing that I actually really
enjoyed that day and it's a good memory
and that's just how I kept it in my bank
but even though it's not like what it
was it was right right pretty painful
but yeah hey I'll take the good memory I
mean
I really appreciate it I I felt bad when
I did Anthony I brought up the Smosh
movie as well and I felt bad that was
classic I was like I felt bad I was like
it was bad [ __ ] yeah I didn't see that
Ninja on we have to like bring back
bring out like the [ __ ] what did he
do like first Fortnight yeah I mean yeah
that was my fortnite floss movement
yeah it's one of those when you're like
young YouTuber and you just like someone
asks you to do [ __ ] and you're like yeah
yeah I can do that it's like you're the
you're the big YouTuber company tells
you you should go do this thing because
we don't really understand it but we
know you're a big deal Go on stage
are you guys are going on tour we are
yes
no singing no promises so maybe by the
time all you guys need to do is do
karaoke mistakes people love it it'll be
great all three of us need to take on me
an honor to Felix yes please do it if we
do a Sweden tour we'll do it oh yeah
no you're in America that's right yeah
yeah maybe one day maybe one day we'll
do a Europe tour and everything
hopefully cool have you done have you
done like a live tour no no no no
luckily I have not done that I've only
done like ever one signing tour for my
book which is fun but no nothing did you
ever would you ever want to no [ __ ] that
all right I mean Jack Jack spoke so
highly of the idea and was like yeah I
love touring and yeah I think he just he
had a good experience yeah yeah really
good frame yeah yeah because he's like
he said once he started Touring that was
like that was it for him he wanted to do
nothing else but at all compared to like
doing YouTube I guess people are
different some people respond more to
having a direct feedback from an
audience and yeah really enjoy that you
get sold on that I'm like yeah stay away
it's like streaming but light right I
swear yeah I guess yeah yeah
I know streaming is the diet version
yeah yeah
by the way it's nice to know that there
is a fellow Pizza cross hater
I remember so because the thing is I
always eat pizza with a knife and fork
yeah sorry
come on that's uh come on actually do
you can feel like Felix
if it's like I do it if it's a really
really good pizza right not not Domino's
if it's like Stone baked you know I I
would prefer to eat with a knife and
forth yeah honestly because it spills
less less over exactly and you can
choose like the exact piece that you
want to like buy every time and it's
it's awesome it's all those perfect
pieces
are slicing up the pizzas like taking I
don't know how long no it comes with
proceeding right away
okay
most pizza places
[Music]
Italy every time I went to Italy they
would always give you the pizza uncut
and it pissed me off so much like hey
[ __ ] off
what's up with that why do they do that
I don't know [ __ ] I don't know maybe
forward that question I remember I
thought it was normal to even the knife
and fork Pizza I mean I remember because
I I always get every time I go eat pizza
with people I've had to like condition
myself if it's like new people I like
okay I'll play on YouTube
I'll eat I'll eat the crust and I'll
like slices
I remember the first time I thought it
was normal like I ate in UK and then I'm
I'm just like enjoying my pizza and then
I look up and everyone's like staring at
me and we're still killed someone like
what's the problem like a Russian
what the [ __ ] are you doing I'm enjoying
my pizza yeah way God intended exactly
exactly I've had to like this is how you
know you if you're good friends with me
is if I eat a pizza with a knife and
fork in front of you that's how you know
because that's
[ __ ] about yourself
I'm comfortable I I do not need to
conform to social norms if it's super
sloppy it all just falls off then yeah I
mean you have no choice because you're
otherwise you're just like I would get
like a fork to kind of like scoop it
yeah I do that as well like I wouldn't
cut it so you do use the net no no I use
it as a leverage if it turns into a soup
one I pick it up I guess I have no
choice yeah that's why we never had the
problem yeah okay how do your calzone
then
well you can't pick up a calzone that's
monstrous that's the point eating a
piece of a knife and fork you basically
just like turn into your basically quite
a calzone to the pizza in that sense
it's not it kind of is because you're
like it's it's just a wrapped up piece
it's just a different dishes
[Music]
okay chili dog is [ __ ] Messier [ __ ]
sometimes I don't want to get all that
[ __ ] on my hands man no [ __ ] no that
that's the fun part that's how you know
it's a good hearty meal when it's like
messy you don't need a [ __ ] Taco we
have civilization for a reason Jerry
sometimes do you eat a taco with a knife
and fork why are you a talking no no
that's just ridiculous
that's completely different like levels
like chili dogs are like way more
messier than the taco that's part of the
tacos are like nice yes
they're like perfectly hand-sized a
chili dog like a good chili dog will
like spill everywhere you know it's it's
the ratio there's way more there's right
there's way more chili like you're on
trash tasting
I feel like having this
good tanks we try not to do this every
day yeah